hey 42 here twenty-two point five five
zero zero degrees north 91 point three
six six seven degrees west those are the
coordinates for Bo Mecca island in the
Gulf of Mexico its name comes from its
reddish color as you can see on this map
it's only a smallish island roughly 80
square kilometers but there's something
really odd about it it isn't there in
1997 a group of Mexican fishermen sailed
out to the location of boo Mecca and
found nothing again in 2009 and Mexican
University conducted a large search and
found no such island just endless deep
blue sea but this makes no sense it
definitely should be here the Spanish
cartographers drew Bamako Island in the
fifteen and sixteen hundreds and between
the 16th and 20th centuries numerous
maps drawn up by different nations all
placed by Mecca in the exact same
location one can only assume they
genuinely did find dry land at that spot
in the ocean it's not the only island
that appears on old maps yet cannot be
found today it takes and the island off
the coast of eastern Australia it has
appeared on nautical maps since the 19th
century sandy island even shows up on
Google Maps as a weird black shape but
when Australian scientists sailed there
to investigate all they found was water
most missing islands like Sandy Island
are no more than curiosities or
anomalies but boo Mecca is surrounded by
tens politics which makes finding it or
discovering what happened to it of top
priority for Mexico in recent decades
Mexico has been so determined to locate
this mysterious missing island because
of you guessed it oil under the 1982
United Nations Convention each country
owns the mineral rights and fish
rights are 200 nautical miles going out
from all directions of that country's
land mass this 200 mile radius is called
an exclusive economic zone or EEZ but a
country's landmass of course also
includes any islands it may own and yes
even if that island is a hundred miles
out at sea that country owns the natural
resources of 200 miles around that
Island as well as its main lands so
owning Islands can hugely extend a
nation's EEZ beyond its usual borders
this is exactly why Mexico so
desperately wants Bamako Island to exist
the location where per Mecca supposedly
once was happens to be the farthest
north of any of Mexico's highlands in
the Gulf of Mexico so laying claim to it
would push Mexico's EEZ hundreds of
miles further north than its current
situation and to make Galland an even
more attractive prize the 200 miles
around bur Mecca Island's location
happened to be rich with pockets of
underground oil millions of barrels
worth finding boo Mecca would allow
Mexico to get their hands on this sticky
black gold instead of America yet no
matter how many times Mexico searched
for it the rocky island remains
frustratingly elusive which is annoying
because it has fantastic Google reviews
as one five-star review had described it
amazing took my family there over the
summer sad that there was just open
waters in no island and my son Timmy
drowned then some helicopters came in
and started shooting at us I would
definitely recommend going there not
only does boom occur up here on
countless of maps but there are reports
less than 10 years ago of Mexican
fishermen coming across the isle
enjoying their travels they usually
report seeing a small spit of red land
and the location shown on the maps but
official searchers have never had such
success and there is no photographic
evidence of the island ever existing
Fuhrman Islands that is supposed to be 8
kilometres to simply disappear he's
beyond weird so what is going on here
many theories have been thrown out to
explain the disappearance of the mecha
it could be that rising sea levels from
climate change have drowned it but this
is unlikely it would have to be a very
small island for the small change in the
sea levels to have claimed it by now
also when the National Autonomous
University of Mexico went to investigate
in 2009 they didn't just sailor dingey
around in circles for an hour they used
advanced ultrasounds to image to
seafloor to a depth of 472 meters in an
area of 223 square kilometers and they
found no sign of an underwater islands
that could have once been above sea
level another explanation is that it
could have been a particularly delicate
landmass made of perhaps coral hands
therefore the sea may have eroded it
away over the past few decades but the
few eyewitness reports there are speak
of a rocky and sandy islands not coral
though one has to wonder how reliable
are the reports of drunk Mexican
fishermen it could simply be that the
coordinates are incorrect and boo Mecca
does exist but in an entirely different
area of the Gulf of Mexico than what is
shown on the maps you may think that an
island couldn't simply hide in the 21st
century but that would be under
estimating the unfathomable vastness of
the ocean whilst extremely unlikely it's
not out of the realms of possibility
though satellite imagery makes the
chances of this vanishingly small
perhaps the most believable explanation
for the mysterious missing islands is
that it never existed in the first place
so how can it possibly appear on
different maps cartography is an art
form before the 20th century maps were
completely hand-drawn and there were
only a few people in the world with
sufficient maps and art skills to be
able to draw detailed and accurate maps
the Italians in English were
particularly good at it with map
creation being so difficult and
essential to ruling the waves
nation-states would seek to
TEKT maps as though they were nuclear
launch codes one method of detecting
copycat map fraudsters was by inventing
islands cartographers would often draw
fake islands on their maps these islands
didn't exist in the real world but if
anyone copied their maps they would
instantly know because they would
invariably copy the fake islands to its
therefore extremely likely that boo
Mecca was a trap island placed there by
an early 16th century Spanish
cartographer knowing full well that it
didn't exist with the sole intention of
catching out rival map makers who also
drew the mecca into their maps and
possibly many did all the subsequent
maps that have shown by Mecca down the
centuries could have simply copied it
from the earlier maps but there is an
even more outlandish explanation to
Bible Mecca may no longer exist
of course when an island disappears into
thin air or water every lonely man in
his caste is going to invent a juicy
conspiracy
some say that bur Mecca was blown up by
the Americans specifically the CIA at
some point during the past few decades
why well to stop Mexico expanding their
easy and getting their hands on all of
that oil of course it sounds utterly
ridiculous that an entire island could
be blown up but with us firepower it's
absolutely possible nobody can prove
whether or not the Americans blew up the
mecca but one has to ask how much
importance does the u.s. put on oil and
what end would they go to to claim it
thanks for watching
I've just launched my first book which
I'm crowdfunding through unbound
publishing it's called sticker flagging
it's a thousand years of bizarre history
from Britain and beyond if you want to
get your hands on a first edition signed
copy then head on over to unbound the
links in the description check out the
launch video over there if you haven't
already and pledge today thank you